All right, lady, you know that Lee was just shooting his movie in Oklahoma City. And the movie gave him a place to stay because he was there for months. Right. But for two of those weeks, me and the kids came out to join him and the place he was staying in that the movie provided. It was just too small to your whole family. We're a whole family. He went on Airbnb, got us the most beautiful, spacious place to stay. With the nicest host. Well you know if you're planning a trip or you're working
好吧，女士，你知道李刚才在俄克拉荷马城拍电影。剧组给他安排了住处，因为他要在那里待上好几个月。没错。但其中有两周，我和孩子们过去和他团聚，剧组提供的那个地方。对你们一整个家庭来说实在太小了。我们是一个大家庭。他上了爱彼迎，给我们找了一个最美丽、宽敞的住处。房东人也超级好。如果你正在计划一次旅行或者在某地工作，
somewhere and you want to stay at an Airbnb, I think you guys got to check out their guest favorite because those are the most loved homes on Airbnb. Oh! We were a guest favorite! We were in a guest favorite! You scared me! So sorry, it's true! You're so excited! I was. Well, yeah, I mean, you're actually getting a home other people have stayed in, and you know it's been well reviewed. Well, listen, we are huge fans of Airbnb for so many reasons.
想在爱彼迎住下来，我觉得你们一定要去看看他们的“房客最爱”，因为那是爱彼迎上最受喜爱的住宅。哦！我们就是“房客最爱”！我们住的就是“房客最爱”！你吓到我了！太抱歉了，这是真的！你太激动了！我是挺激动的。不过，对啊，我的意思是，你实际上是住进了一套别人住过的房子，而且你知道它有着很好的评价。听着，我们是爱彼迎的超级粉丝，原因有很多。
So for your next adventure, consider Airbnb. Okay, Martin, let's try one. Remember, big. You got it. The Ford It's a Big Deal event is on. How's that? A little bigger. The Ford It's a Big Deal event. Nice.
所以，为了你的下一次冒险，考虑一下爱彼迎吧。好了，马丁，我们来录一个。记住，要有气势。没问题。福特“超值大促”活动正在进行。怎么样？再大声一点。福特“超值大促”活动。不错。
Now the offer? Lease a 2025 Escape Active all-wheel drive from 198 bi-weekly at 1.99% APR for 36 months with 27.55 down. Wow, that's like $99 a week. Yeah, it's a big deal. The Ford, it's a big deal event. Visit your Toronto area Ford store or ford.ca today.
现在有什么优惠？租赁2025款Escape Active全驱版，每两周198起，年利率1.99%，期限36个月，首付27.55。哇，那相当于每周99美元左右。对，这可是个大优惠。福特，“超值大促”活动。今天就光临您的多伦多地区福特门店或访问ford.ca了解详情。
I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details, and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Ladies 6.0.
我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一同出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们为你打造了终极的办公室爱好者播客。每周，我们将深入探讨《办公室》的世界，带来独家采访、幕后细节以及大量VFF的故事。我们是《办公室女士》6.0版。
Hello. Good morning. Oh, I'm excited about today. Me too. Today warms my heart. Warms my heart, brought me joy, and it's all because of you guys. That's right, and tell everybody what we're doing today. Well, we are covering two very funny fan theories.
你好。早安。哦，我对今天充满期待。我也是。今天暖透了我的心。暖透了我的心，带给我快乐，这一切都是因为你们。没错，告诉大家我们主要聊什么。我们要讨论两个非常有趣的粉丝理论。
Yes, you guys had a lot to say about our Is Toby the Scranton Strangler fan theory, so we thought we would explore a few more that you have made us aware of. But you guys, we're not gonna debate these two like we did Toby's the Scranton Strangler, although I would really like to do another debate. I would as well. Yes, we need to find another debate topic.
是的，关于“托比是斯克兰顿勒喉狂”这个粉丝理论，你们发表了大量看法，所以我们觉得可以再探索一些你们让我们了解到的新理论。不过大家注意，我们不会像讨论“托比是斯克兰顿勒喉狂”那样来辩论这两个理论，尽管我真的很想再来一场辩论。我也很想。对，我们需要找个新的辩论话题。
Yeah, if you have any ideas. Yeah, hit us up. Yeah. But today we're gonna do more of a deep dive. Yeah. I took one, Angela took the other. I took, is Bob Vance in the Scranton Mafia? I have thoughts.
对，如果你有什么好点子。随时联系我们。对。不过今天我们要进行更深入的探讨。一人挑了一个，我选了一个，安吉拉选了另一个。我选的是，鲍勃·范斯在斯克兰顿黑手党里吗？我有一些想法。
I have lots of fan evidence. OK. Saying that he is. And I'm going to tackle a fan theory, you guys. It's pretty out there. But it's called, is the office actually hell? I mean, you told me about this. Is Dunder Mifflin where you go if you go to the bad place?
我有大量粉丝提供的证据。好吧。证明他确实在其中。而我要探讨的粉丝理论，各位。可以说是相当离谱。但它的名字叫，办公室其实是地狱吗？我的意思是，你跟我提过这个。当德米夫林公司是你去了坏地方之后才会去的地方吗？
Oh, boy. Oh, boy. But before we get to our fan theories, we also wanted to dive into some of the things we have found in our office ladies mailbag. Because we picked up more mail from our PO box and we suddenly got a delivery that had been sitting at Earwolf since 2023.
哦，天哪。哦，天哪。但在我们讨论粉丝理论之前，我们还想深入聊聊我们在《办公室女士》收件箱里发现的一些东西。因为我们从邮政信箱里收到了更多信件，而且我们突然收到了一个自2023年起就一直放在Earwolf的快递。
Oh you guys, we love hearing from you. And here's the thing, you know what? We were both saying, we're so thankful they didn't toss it out. So thank you for bringing it to us. And we went through it. And it was just, it was such a special day, Ange. It meant the world to us.
哦，伙计们，我们太喜欢听你们分享了。而且关键是，你知道吗？我们俩当时都在说，非常庆幸他们没有把它扔掉。所以感谢你们把它送给我们。我们翻看了一遍。那真的是非常特别的一天，安琪。这对我们意义重大。
It really was, Jenna. You know, we were both so moved that you all take the time to sit down and write us letters and cards. And we were reading them, and we were laughing, and we were tearing up and we would interrupt each other. We'd say, wait, wait, you have to hear this. You have to hear this. Or we would hold something up and you know, just thank you so much for your kindness.
确实如此，珍娜。你知道，你们花时间坐下来给我们写信和制作卡片，我们俩都感动不已。我们在读着这些信，有时开怀大笑，有时感动得热泪盈眶，还会忍不住打断对方。我们会说：“等等，等等，你得听听这个。你得听听这个。”或者我们会举起某样东西，你知道的，只想对你们的善良表达万分感谢。
Yes. Your mail, it made us laugh. It made us cry. We appreciate you sharing with us and we're excited to share some of the treasures now with everyone. Yeah. Angela, do you want to kick us off? I will. I'm going to kick us off. I mean, this just tickled me. I want to shout out Dana L. from Los Angeles. Dana wrote us a card sharing what The Office and our podcast mean to her. They really kept her company and brought her joy. And she says she appreciates our positivity, our friendship,
是的。你们的信，让我们开怀大笑，让我们感动落泪。我们非常感谢你们与我们分享，现在我们也很高兴能和大家一起分享其中的一些宝藏。太棒了。安吉拉，你想带个头吗？好的。我来带个头。我的意思是，这真的把我逗乐了。我要向来自洛杉矶的达娜·L.（Dana L.）致以谢意。达娜给我们写了一张卡片，分享了《办公室》和我们的播客对她的意义。它们真的陪伴了她并带给她快乐，她说她很欣赏我们的积极态度、我们的友谊，
and womanhood. Then she said, please accept this silly book as a token of my deep gratitude. You guys, it's a book titled, What Would Keanu Do? When Angela opened this package, she squealed. I did. We got so excited. Listen to this title. It's What Would Keanu Do? And then underneath it, it says, Personal Philosophy and Awe-Inspiring Advice from the Patron Saint of Woe. Again. Again. Keanu as a Patron Saint on the cover.
以及女性情谊。然后她说，请收下这本愚蠢的书，作为我深深感激的象征。你们看，这本书的书名是《基努会怎么做？》（What Would Keanu Do?）安吉拉打开这个包裹时，尖叫出声了。我确实叫了。我们太兴奋了。听听这个书名。就是《基努会怎么做？》然后在它下方写着：苦难守护神的个人哲学与醍醐灌顶的建议。再读一遍。封面上的基努就是守护神。
Yes. It is written by Chris Barsanti. Here is the summary of the book. It says, this book examines everyday challenges people face and help solve the same problems by applying the philosophical lessons exposed by Keanu Reeves or one of his films. So if I gave you a problem right now, could you open up to a page in the book and tell me how to solve it? Possibly.
对。这本书是克里斯·巴尔桑蒂（Chris Barsanti）写的。以下是这本书的内容简介。它写道：这本书探讨了人们日常面临的挑战，并通过应用基努·里维斯或他的某部电影中所揭示的哲学教训，来帮助解决同样的问题。所以，如果我现在给你出个难题，你能翻开书中的某一页告诉我怎么解决吗？可能吧。
All right. It also has, and I'm quoting, Keanu dotes. Okay. Like. Antic dotes quoting, Keanu dotes. Okay. Antic dotes, but Keanu dotes. Keanu dotes. Here's one of them, and this is from Keanu himself, not one of his characters. The simple act of paying attention can take you a long way.
好吧。它里面还有，我引用的，基努语录（Keanu dotes）。好吧。就像。幽默轶事（Antic dotes）引用自基努语录。好吧。轶事，但叫基努语录。基努语录。这里有一条，这是基努本人说的，而不是他饰演的角色。简单的关注这一行为就能让你受益匪浅。
So just sit with that. Can I see this book? Okay. All right, I don't know who needs to hear this, but trust your gut. For Point Breaks, Johnny Utah, buying two meatball subs is a lesson in listening to your instincts.
所以好好体会一下这句话。我能看看这本书吗？好吧。好吧，我不知道谁需要听这个，但请相信你的直觉。对于《惊爆点》里的强尼·犹他来说，买两个肉丸潜艇三明治就是一门倾听直觉的学课。
I mean, Johnny Utah, it's a deep thinker. Didn't he also say surf's up, brah? Well, Dana, thank you for that. That is no doubt a gift that's going to keep on giving. We might have to bring up some Keanu. Keanectotes. Keanectotes as we move move along Office Lady 6.0. Loved it.
我的意思是，强尼·犹他，他是个深刻的思想家。他是不是还说过“冲浪去吧，兄弟”？好吧，达娜，谢谢你。这无疑是一份会带来不断惊喜的礼物。随着《办公室女士》6.0版的推进，我们可能得聊聊基努。基努语录。基努语录。太棒了。
Well, we would also like to give a very big thank you to Martha G. from Virginia. Martha, we got your Christmas pillows. They are so stinkin' cute. They're amazing. They came with sweet handmade cards. Mine had an orange cat, Angela, yours had a hummingbird. We love these pillows. And you know what I love about them? They're circles.
好吧，我们还要向来自弗吉尼亚州的玛莎·G.（Martha G.）表示衷心的感谢。玛莎，我们收到了你送的圣诞抱枕。它们实在是太可爱了。太棒了。它们还附带了温馨的手工卡片。我的上面有一只橙色的猫，安吉拉，你的上面有一只蜂鸟。我们超爱这些抱枕。你知道我最喜欢它们哪一点吗？它们是圆的。
Everybody, I want you to... When I said pillow, you probably thought square. But oh no, they are like a patchwork pattern, like you might see on a quilt. And they are a circle. And I literally can't wait to put mine out next Christmas. I can't wait. I'm going gonna put this out every single Christmas. Yes, every Christmas. Martha, thank you. Thank you. It was our biggest box. We were excited about it.
各位，我想让你们……当我提到抱枕时，你们可能脑海中浮现的是正方形。但哦，不，它们就像是拼布图案，就像你在被子上可能看到的那种。而且它们是圆的。我简直迫不及待想在下一个圣诞节把我的拿出来摆上了。我等不及了。我每一个圣诞节都要把它摆出来。对，每一个圣诞节。玛莎，谢谢你。谢谢你。这是我们收到的最大的一个箱子。我们当时可兴奋了。
We thought, what's inside this giant box? You made our day. Next up for me, y'all know I love a wedding. I love a wedding. And I just want to give a shout out to every single person that sent us baby announcements, graduations, and of course weddings. You are so creative with your announcements and invitations. I mean I'm just gonna highlight a few but I love them all. First up, Brittany Z in Lafayette,
我们在想，这个巨大的箱子里装的是什么？你让我们这一天都变得美好了。接下来对我来说，各位，你们都知道我很喜欢婚礼。我很喜欢婚礼。我只想对每一位给我们寄来婴儿降生喜讯、毕业喜讯以及当然还有婚礼邀请函的人表达谢意。你们在制作喜讯和请柬时真的太有创意了。我的意思是，我只想重点展示几个，但我每一个都好喜欢。首先是来自拉斐特的布里塔尼·Z.（Brittany Z.），
Colorado. She sent us a hand-stitched stapler in Jell-O with her wedding announcement. Oh my goodness. Isn't that so cute? Yes. I opened the invitation, I didn't know this was gonna fall out of it. This is adorable. So creative.
科罗拉多州。她随婚礼请柬寄给我们一个手工缝制的果冻订书机。哦天哪。这不是超级可爱吗？是的。我打开请柬时，根本不知道这里面会掉出来这个。这也太可爱了吧。太有创意了。
Then we got a wedding invitation from Kelsey. She wrote us to tell us how much she loved the podcast. And she also sent us a Keanu Reeves coloring book. My goodness. And then she said, I know how much you gals love weddings. So I wanted to share my wedding invitation. It's from 2016. But Jenna, this is so creative. I mean, it looks like a book. It looks like you're holding a little book. Yes. So her and her husband Walker got married in Georgia and their wedding had a book theme. Come on, their invitation is like a little book
然后我们收到了凯尔西（Kelsey）的婚礼请柬。她写信告诉我们她有多喜欢这个播客。她还给我们寄了一本基努·里维斯的填色书。天哪。然后她说，我知道你们这些女士有多喜欢婚礼。所以我想分享我的婚礼请柬。这是2016年的。但是珍娜，这太有创意了。我的意思是，它看起来像一本书。看起来你手里拿的是一本小书。是的。所以她和她的丈夫沃克（Walker）在佐治亚州结的婚，他们的婚礼有个书籍主题。你们看，他们的邀请函就像一本小书，
and when you open it up, it's like the library card. Do you see the library card? This is definitely the most creative wedding invitation I've ever seen. Yeah, and look, you pull out the like catalog card, like if you've checked out the book from the library. Yes. And then that's where you check if you're accepting or going.
而且当你打开它时，就像是借书卡。你看到借书卡了吗？这绝对是我见过最有创意的婚礼请柬。是的，你看，你可以把那个目录卡抽出来，就像你从图书馆借书时那样。是的。然后那就是你勾选是否出席或赴宴的地方。
That's the thing you send back. Yes. Wow. Isn't that so cute? I just couldn't get over it. I'll put it in our stories. So creative. Next, I wanted to share this sweet note from Elise.
那是你要寄回的东西。是的。哇。是不是超级可爱？我简直无法释怀。我会把它发到我们的快拍里。太有创意了。接下来，我想分享来自爱丽丝（Elise）的这封温馨便条。
She married Zayid this past month in Arizona, and she sent us the cutest little stationery. Look at this little cat. So cute. And this is what she wrote. Dear Jenna and Angela, in 2019, my dad told me he thought I'd like a new podcast. It was made by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
她上个月在亚利桑那州嫁给了扎伊德（Zayid），她给我们寄来了最可爱的小文具。看这只小猫。太可爱了。这是她写的信。亲爱的珍娜和安吉拉，在2019年，我爸爸告诉我，他觉得我会喜欢一个新的播客。那是珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作的。
I became an avid office ladies listener right away. It was right around the same time that I started dating this new guy, dot dot dot. I love a dot dot dot. All these years later, and I've never stopped listening to your pod, and I'm about to marry that guy. Wow.
我立刻成了《办公室女士》的忠实听众。那正是我开始和这个新男友约会的大致时间，点点点。我太喜欢点点点（省略号）了。这么多年过去了，我从未停止收听你们的播客，而我马上就要和那个男生结婚了。哇。
It feels like your podcast has been such a real and meaningful part of this time in my life. And I can't think of any better ladies and besties to truly be my own besties and favorite storytellers and most of all, two amazing moms during this chapter of my own life and girlhood. Thanks for all that you do. And they got married this year in January of 2025.
感觉你们的播客一直是我生命中这段时期真实而有意义的一部分。在这个属于我自己的生活章节和少女时代里，我想不出还有什么比你们更棒的女士和闺蜜，能真正成为我的死党、最爱的故事讲述者，最重要的是，成为两个了不起的妈妈。感谢你们所做的一切。他们今年2025年1月结婚了。
Congratulations and a big thank you to Elise's dad. Right? Thank you. Isn't that so sweet? Yes. And then look, Sam Cassie, she said, PS. Hi Sam, hi Cassie. Hi.
恭喜并向爱丽丝的爸爸致以诚挚的谢意。对吧？谢谢。是不是超级温馨？是的。然后看，萨姆·卡茜（Sam Cassie），她说，PS。嗨，萨姆，嗨，卡茜。嗨。
Hi Elise, congratulations on your wedding. Lastly, I wanna shout out Dan and Andrea who sent out the cutest little invite cards that said, it is our wedding, with the balloons. Oh, that's so cute. And they invited us all to their wedding. They said, don't worry, we promise we didn't steal any of Pam's ideas and we won't kid... And we won't kidnap Angela. They said they're still debating where to take their mini moon, maybe Niagara or Scranton.
嗨，爱丽丝，祝贺你们新婚快乐。最后，我要感谢丹（Dan）和安德里亚（Andrea），他们寄出了最可爱的小邀请卡，上面写着，这是我们的婚礼，还有气球图案。哦，太可爱了。他们邀请我们所有人去参加他们的婚礼。他们说，别担心，我们保证没有偷用帕姆的任何创意，我们也不会绑架……而且我们不会绑架安吉拉。他们说他们还在讨论要把蜜月旅行（mini moon）定在哪里，可能是尼亚加拉瀑布或者斯克兰顿。
Aww. But anyway, so cute. Everyone is so creative. Thank you for sharing your invitations with us. I love seeing your baby announcements. The graduation invites all of it. Well, lady, I opened a couple that I want to share as well. First of all, speaking of books, we got a baby shower announcement from way back in July 2023. It was honoring Michelle D from Carmel, New York.
噢。不管怎样，太可爱了。每个人都太有创意了。感谢你们与我们分享你们的请柬。我喜欢看你们的婴儿降生喜讯。毕业邀请函，全都有。好吧，女士，我也拆了几封信想跟大家分享。首先，说到书，我们收到了一封早在2023年7月寄出的迎婴派对喜讯。它是为了庆祝来自纽约州卡梅尔的米歇尔·D.（Michelle D.）。
And here's what I loved. Now, I know this has become, I think, kind of popular with baby showers, but I sure wish this was around when I had my babies. She said, one small request, please was around when I had my babies. She said, one small request, please bring a book instead of a card. By signing your book, we'll remember and share your special gift even when you're not there. Oh, like a children's book? Yes, this has become a trend where at baby showers, you bring a children's book
而我最喜欢的是这个。现在，我知道这已经变得，我觉得在迎婴派对上挺流行的，但我真的希望我生孩子的时候也有这个。她说，一个小小的请求，请在我生孩子的时候准备好这个。她说，一个小小的请求，请带一本书而不是一张卡片。通过在书上签名，即使你不在场，我们也会记住并分享你这份特别的礼物。哦，就像儿童读物吗？是的，现在这成了一种趋势，在迎婴派对上，你带一本儿童读物，
and you write a little message in it. And then your child kind of starts off with a library filled with not just great books, but messages from loved ones. This is so wonderful. I loved it. Yeah. I think this is a thing now.
并在上面写下一小段寄语。然后你的孩子就会从一个藏书丰富的图书馆开始人生，这里不仅有好书，还有来自挚爱之人的寄语。这太棒了。我太喜欢了。是的。我觉得现在这很流行。
Don't you wish that you had that? I do. Same. Especially because people who are parents before you, they know the good ones. Yep. You might know a few from your childhood, but then they'll be like,
难道你没希望自己当初也有这个吗？我有。一样。尤其是因为比你先当父母的人，他们知道哪些书是好书。没错。你可能知道童年时的几本，但接着他们会说，
oh, you also need to read this one, or that's a great gift. You know which one I always give as a baby shower gift? Which one? The tiger who came to tea. My kids loved it. It is like, I think over in the UK, this is like in the world of like Good Night Moon.
哦，你还必须读读这本，或者这是个极好的礼物。你知道我作为迎婴派对礼物总是送哪一本吗？哪一本？《来喝下午茶的老虎》（The Tiger Who Came to Tea）。我孩子们超爱这本书。它就像，我觉得在英国，这就像是《晚安月亮》（Good Night Moon）那种级别的经典。
Because the British know this book. And it was actually a British person who gave it to me and my kids absolutely adored it. It's about a tiger who comes over and eats all the food. Came for tea and ate all the food. I think it's an oldie but a goodie over there. Well, one of the books my mom saved from when I was a little one and I still have it was
因为英国人都知道这本书。实际上是一个英国人把它送给了我和我的孩子们，他们超级喜欢它。讲的是一只老虎来串门，把所有的食物都吃光了。来喝茶然后吃光了所有的食物。我觉得那是一本在那边经久不衰的老书。好吧，我妈妈在我小的时候保存下来并我一直留着的一本书是，
The Story of Ferdinand. Oh, yes. Yeah. So I read my actual copy of Growing Up to Isabel and it's still in publication. So that's one that I give as a gift. Well, I also want to shout out a big congratulations to Mackenzie M. who sent us her graduation announcement from Arizona College of Nursing. She's a nurse. Mackenzie, thank you. We need nurses. Yes. And good luck in your new career. Next up is a letter that we got from Camille in Tennessee,
《爱花的牛》（The Story of Ferdinand）。哦，是的。是的，所以我把我的那本童年藏书读给了伊莎贝尔听，而且它现在还在出版。所以那是我会作为礼物送人的一本书。好吧，我也要向麦肯齐·M.（Mackenzie M.）表示热烈的祝贺，她给我们寄来了她在亚利桑那护理学院的毕业喜讯。她是一名护士。麦肯齐，谢谢你。我们需要护士。是的。祝你在新职业中一切顺利。接下来是一封我们收到来自田纳西州卡米尔（Camille）的信，
and it just warmed my heart. Camille says that she listens to the Office Ladies podcast to keep her company. She lives with her cat Dolly Parton. And she says whenever she gets home and sees Dolly, she says, Hey, lady, Camille, thank you so much for your letter. It just brought me so much joy and hi to Dolly Parton. Hey, lady. And then also she went to Iceland and she went to the penis museum and she said the biggest one there is the sperm whale penis. Here's a picture of her with it. She sent a polaroid, a tiny polaroid from the penis museum.
这真的温暖了我的心。卡米尔说她听《办公室女士》播客来陪伴自己。她和她的猫多莉·帕顿（Dolly Parton）住在一起。她说每当她回到家看到多莉，她就会说：“嘿，女士。”卡米尔，非常感谢你的信。它真的带给我巨大的快乐，也代我向多莉·帕顿问好。嘿，女士。然后还有，她去了冰岛，去了阴茎博物馆，她说那里最大的是抹香鲸的阴茎。这是她和它的合影。她寄来了一张宝丽来照片，一张来自阴茎博物馆的微型宝丽来。
That is incredible. This is her and Dolly, Dolly Parton. What a great name for her cat. I thought that was so cute. Anyway, Camille, just thank you for your letter. It just, it brought me joy. Well, I love the reminder that we need to get to this penis museum.
这太不可思议了。这是她和多莉，多莉·帕顿。给她猫起这个名字真棒。我觉得这太可爱了。不管怎样，卡米尔，谢谢你的信。它真的，带给我快乐。好吧，我喜欢这个提醒，我们得去一趟这个阴茎博物馆。
We need to make this a real goal. We're very good, Angela, when we get determined and we set a goal, we make it happen. So I think we need to really make this a real goal. Well, Josh wants to go to Iceland. He keeps bringing it up. And I'm like, babe, I don't know if I can go there without Jenna.
我们需要把这定为一个切实的目标。安吉拉，我们很厉害的，当我们下定决心设定一个目标时，我们一定会实现它。所以我觉得我们真的需要把这当作一个切实的目标。好吧，乔什想去冰岛。他一直提起这事。而我就像，宝贝，我不知道没有珍娜我能不能去那儿。
I guess am I coming on your family trip this year? Maybe. Just for I'll pop over for one day of your family vacation. OK. Well, I've got another place for us to go as well. We got a letter from Amanda B. in Allentown, Pennsylvania, whose daughter's name is Cece, by the way. And I want to thank you for including your photo
我想我是不是要加入你们今年的家庭旅行？也许吧。就为了……我会去你们的家庭度假中客串一天。好吧。好吧，我还有另一个地方也想让我们去。我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州阿伦敦的阿曼达·B.（Amanda B.）的信，顺便说一句，她女儿的名字叫西西（Cece）。我想感谢你附上了你在
of the Titanic Museum in Tennessee. Jenna is now obsessed with this Titanic Museum. I looked it up. It looks incredible. Amanda, she really wants to go. I really want to go. It's like this immersive experience where you go on the boat and you learn all about
田纳西州泰坦尼克号博物馆的照片。珍娜现在对这个泰坦尼克号博物馆着迷了。我查过了。看起来太不可思议了。阿曼达，她真的很想去。我真的很想去。这就像是一个身临其境的体验，你登上这艘船，了解关于
the boat itself, which, Ann, come on, you love a ship. I love a boat. Yeah. Boats and trains, sign me up. Boat facts. And then you learn about all the people who were on the boat and they have built a boat. I think they built something that looks like the inside,
船本身的一切，安琪，拜托，你最喜欢船了。我喜欢船。是的。船只和火车，算我一个。有关船的趣事。然后你了解所有在船上的人，他们还造了一艘船。我想他们造了一个看起来像内部结构的东西，
the grand staircase. Yeah, no, I would love it. I mean, I wanna see this Viking ship that they found at the bottom of the ocean and they rebuilt it and you can go see it. Where's that? I don't know, I just, I don't know. You know that it's somewhere.
大楼梯。对，不，我会喜欢的。我的意思是，我想看看他们在海洋底部找到的那艘维京船，他们重建了它，你可以去参观。在哪儿？我不知道，我只是，我不知道。你知道它在某个地方。
I know it exists. It's somewhere, we're gonna go to it. I've heard about it, I've heard about it. I read about it's somewhere. I know it exists. It's somewhere. I've heard about it. We're gonna go to it. I've heard about it. I read about it. It was interesting to me too. All right, maybe we need to pick a theme
我知道它存在。它在某个地方，我们要去参观。我听说过，我听说过。我读到过它在某个地方。我知道它存在。它在某个地方。我听说过。我们要去参观。我听说过。我读到过。这对我来说也很有趣。好吧，也许我们需要为我们的旅行选个主题，
for some of our travel. Like what if we did a year of ships and we just went around and like looked at ships. Year of ships. Oh my God, I love it. Lady, we could do a year of trains. Year of trains and ships. There is a train ride I really wanna go on.
比如我们搞一个“船只之年”，到处去看看船。船只之年。哦天哪，我太喜欢了。女士，我们可以搞一个“火车之年”。火车和船只之年。有一个火车之旅我真的很想去。
Which one? I mean, there's a few. Yeah. I mean, there's one that goes through Scotland that I've always wanted to do. That's the one, that's the first one that comes to mind. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Also, I believe you're referring to the Osberg ship. It's in Norway.
哪一个？我的意思是，有好几个。是的。我的意思是，有一趟穿过苏格兰的列车，我一直想去坐。就是那个，那是我想到的第一个。好吧。好吧。还有，我相信你指的是奥斯伯格号船（Oseberg ship）。它在挪威。
Thank you, Sam slash Google. Norway. Norway. Seems like a wonderful place to visit. I want to go. Well Amanda B, if we make it to the Titanic Museum in Tennessee, it's because of you. So thank you for writing us. All right, next up is the sweetest postcard that I got. It's a Taylor Swift postcard, and it's addressed to Angela Kinsey, head of the PPC, podcast queen and fellow Swiftie. It cracked me up. It's from Claire, and here's what she had to say. Claire writes, Angela! It was so fun getting to meet you at NOLA. You know, she means New Orleans. You were so incredibly kind and gave me your blue Karma is a Cat friendship bracelet. I think I may have blacked out when I met you because I was so excited that I fear I never gave you a bracelet. I
谢谢你，萨姆/谷歌。挪威。挪威。听起来是个旅游的好地方。我想去。好吧，阿曼达·B，如果我们能去成田纳西州的泰坦尼克号博物馆，那全是因为你。所以谢谢你给我们写信。好吧，接下来是我收到的最温馨明信片。这是一张泰勒·斯威夫特的明信片，收件人是安吉拉·金西，PPC（播客委员会）负责人、播客女王兼同好斯威夫特迷。这把我逗乐了。这是克莱尔（Claire）寄的，她写了这些。克莱尔写道：安吉拉！在诺拉（NOLA）见到你太有趣了。（你知道的，她指的是新奥尔良）。你超级善良，还把你的蓝色“因果报应就是只猫”（Karma is a Cat）友谊手链送给了我。我遇到你时可能有点大脑空白，因为太兴奋了，我生怕自己从来没送你手链。我
made one for you and Jenna as well. I love your podcast and y'all's friendship. Praise in God that Jenna is cancer free and I made the pink bracelet for her. The other one matches your podcast cover photo. Wishing you all a blessed rest of your year, Claire. Oh, that is so thoughtful. I met her at the Taylor Swift concert, you know, the Heiress Tour in New Orleans. Yes. And look, she did, she sent us bracelets.
也为你和珍娜各做了一条。我喜欢你们的播客和你们的友谊。感谢上帝保佑珍娜战胜癌症，我为她做了粉色手链。另一条的颜色和你们播客的封面照片很搭。祝你们今年剩余的日子里充满祝福，克莱尔。哦，这太贴心了。我在泰勒·斯威夫特的演唱会上遇到过她，你知道的，就是在新奥尔良的时代巡回演唱会（The Eras Tour）。是的。看，她真的寄给我们手链了。
Isn't this so sweet? Well, Angela, you know, I went to Taylor's very last show in Vancouver with my daughter and I love the Swifties. The Swifties were great. Isabelle and I had the best time. It was just, just an absolute, like, I mean, just overflowing of like joy and love and positivity. Here's your bracelet.
这不是超级温馨吗？好吧，安吉拉，你知道的，我和我女儿去看了泰勒在温哥华的最后一场演出，我超爱斯威夫特迷（Swifties）。斯威夫特迷们太棒了。我和伊莎贝尔度过了最美好的时光。那简直是，绝对的，我的意思是，充满喜悦、爱与积极能量的满溢。这是你的手链。
You know, a few people sent us friendship bracelets. We love them. Sam and Cassie, you got yours as well. Mm-hmm. They're great. Yeah. Love it. All right.
你知道，有好几个人给我们寄了友谊手链。我们爱死它们了。萨姆和卡茜，你们也收到你们的了吧。嗯——哼。它们太棒了。是的。太棒了。好吧。
Well, as we're finishing up this mailbag section, I did want to just shout out a few letters that were very meaningful to me personally. Several of you have written me about my cancer journey, but you've written me about your own. And I don't want to share personal details of other people, but I want you to know that I have been reading each and every one. Jasmine, Amanda, thank you for your letters
好吧，在我们结束这一段收件箱环节时，我确实想对几封对我个人意义重大的信件表示感谢。你们中的几个人写信跟我谈起我的抗癌之旅，但你们也写到了你们自己的经历。我不想分享其他人的个人隐私，但我想让你们知道，每一封信我都有认真阅读。贾斯敏、阿曼达，谢谢你们的信，
and for sharing with me about your journeys. And just all of you, I just want you to know that I'm reading them and they are really comforting to me. And you all sent me photos as well, and just thank you. And then Angela and I both wanted to just say thank you to Jamie D from North Carolina. Jamie, you wrote us a card just talking about, you know, what happened in Asheville. Yes. After Hurricane Helene hit and that you were part of that community and what that was like for you. And we just wanna say that we're so glad
以及与我分享你们的人生旅程。还有大家所有人，我只是想让你们知道我都在读，它们真的给了我莫大的安慰。你们还给我寄了照片，真的谢谢你们。然后安吉拉和我都想向来自北卡罗来纳州的杰米·D.（Jamie D.）表示感谢。杰米，你给我们写了一张卡片，谈到了（你知道的）阿什维尔发生的那些事。是的。在海伦飓风袭击之后，你也是那个社区的一员，那段经历对你来说是怎样的。我们只想说，我们很高兴
that our podcast brought you some relief during that really trying time, which we know is still ongoing. And we're just, we're thinking of you and we love y'all. Yes. And you know, we thought we would end this top of show with a fun fan encounter. I love meeting people.
我们的播客在那个非常艰难的时期为你带来了一些慰藉，我们知道那场灾难的影响至今仍在持续。我们只想说，我们在惦记着你们，我们爱你们所有人。是的。而且你知道，我们觉得可以用一个有趣的粉丝偶遇来结束节目开场。我喜欢和人见面。
We know this about you, Ann. We know. If you come up and talk to me, I'm gonna chat your ear off. I hope you're not in a hurry. And I was traveling through Austin, Texas a few months ago and I met the nicest lady and she told me such a sweet story
安琪，我们了解你这一点。我们太知道了。如果你走过来跟我说话，我一定会跟你聊个没完。我希望你不是赶时间。几个月前，我在德克萨斯州奥斯汀旅行时，遇到了一个超级好的女士，她给我讲了一个非常温馨的故事，
and I wanted to share it with you all on the podcast. I asked her, I said, hey, can you say it all again and I'll record us? And she was like, okay. So here, this is from my iPhone. Sam, can you play it? Okay, here I am in Austin, Texas, in the ladies' room at the airport, and I just met.
我想在播客上和大家分享。我问她，我说，嘿，你能把刚才的话再说一遍，我录下来吗？她就说，好啊。所以，这是我从iPhone里录的。萨姆，你能放一下吗？好吧，我在这儿，在德克萨斯州奥斯汀，机场的女洗手间里，我刚刚遇到了……
Jamie. And Jamie, will you tell everyone what you just told me? I had both my babies listening to your podcast. Office ladies babies. That's right. Oh my gosh. Like while she was in labor, she was listening to office ladies. Yes, yes.
杰米。杰米，你愿意把刚才对我说的话告诉大家吗？我怀孕时，两个孩子都是听着你们的播客长大的。《办公室女士》的宝宝。没错。哦天哪。就像在她生孩子阵痛时，她都在听《办公室女士》。是的，是的。
And then she was holding her baby as we were talking. And you know, we weren't like in the bathroom stalls. We were like in that little entrance part of, know that you walk through the little hallway and then we both exited the bathroom and our husbands were both outside waiting for us and her husband was like hey because I was like hey I heard you guys listen to the office ladies he was like man we love office ladies. Now I've heard of people who watch the office while they're in labor to distract but oh my gosh she listened to Office Ladies.
然后我们在说话时，她一直抱着她的宝宝。而且你知道，我们不是在洗手间隔间里。我们是在那个小入口区域，你知道的，你穿过那个小走廊，然后我们俩一起走出洗手间，我们的丈夫都在外面等我们，她丈夫就说，嘿，因为我说，嘿，我听说你们听《办公室女士》，他就说，天哪，我们超爱《办公室女士》。现在，我听说过有人在阵痛时看《办公室》来转移注意力，但天哪，她听的是《办公室女士》。
Yes. Her both times. Both times. Oh my gosh. Well, listen, why don't we take a break and when we come back, I will dive into the fan theory. Is Bob Vance part of the Scranton Mafia? I can't wait to hear this because then I want to weigh in. I want...
是的。两个孩子都是。两次都是。哦天哪。好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下，等我们回来，我将深入探讨那个粉丝理论：鲍勃·范斯是斯克兰顿黑手党的一部分吗？我等不及要听了，因为接下来我想发表意见。我想……
I want everybody to vote. Okay. [♪ theme music playing. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades out. Fades your mobile plan, you're not with Fizz. Switch today. Conditions apply. Details at fizz.ca. Hit pause on whatever you're listening to and hit play on your next adventure. Stay two nights and get a $50 Best Western gift card. Life's the trip. Make the most of it at Best Western. Visit bestwestern.com for complete terms and conditions. ["The Daily Show Theme"] All right, we are back, and are you ready to discuss, is Bob Vance in the Scranton Mafia?
我想让大家都来投票。好吧。[♪ 主题音乐播放。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。渐隐。如果你对手机套餐不满意，说明你用的不是Fizz。今天就来换吧。受条款约束。详情请访问fizz.ca。暂停你正在收听的内容，开启你的下一次精彩冒险。连住两晚即可获得50美元的贝斯特韦斯特（Best Western）礼品卡。生活就是一场旅行。在贝斯特韦斯特尽情享受每一刻。访问bestwestern.com了解完整的条款和条件。["每日秀主题曲"] 好吧，我们回来了，你们准备好讨论“鲍勃·范斯是不是斯克兰顿黑手党成员”了吗？
Yes, I am. So when I was going through our digital mailbag, I came across this letter from Megan F. in Omaha, Nebraska, who said, I've been thinking about this for years. I am convinced that Bob Vance is either part of the mafia or a lone shark. Little sprinklings of information throughout the seasons ever since he first appeared has solidified my stance, and I would like to know where you ladies, as well as Sam and Cassie, stand on this take.
是的，我准备好了。所以当我翻看我们的数字收件箱时，我偶然看到了来自内布拉斯加州奥马哈的梅根·F.（Megan F.）的这封信，信中写道：我思考这件事好多年了。我确信鲍勃·范斯要么是黑手党成员，要么是个高利贷。自从他第一次出现以来，贯穿各个季节的零星信息巩固了我的立场，我想知道你们这些女士，还有萨姆和卡茜，对这个看法持什么立场。
But didn't stop there. Also got this letter from Tegan B in Wales, UK, who watches The Office with her daughter Bailey. Tegan wrote in after we broke down the mafia episode and said this, hearing you guys take us through the mafia episode, I had one question on my mind the whole time. Have you guys heard the Bob Vance mob boss fan theory? I thought it was ridiculous when I first
但她并没有就此罢休。我们还收到了来自英国威尔士的蒂根·B.（Tegan B.）的信，她和女儿贝利（Bailey）一起看《办公室》。蒂根在我们剖析了黑手党那一集后写信说：听着你们带我们回顾黑手党那一集时，我脑海里一直有一个问题。你们听说过“鲍勃·范斯是黑手党老大”这个粉丝理论吗？我一开始听到时觉得这太荒谬了，
heard it, but here is the Reddit link. I would love to hear what you guys think on this one, especially after all the deep diving you guys did about mobs and Scranton during the mafia episode. Well, I went to this Reddit thread. It was part of the Dunder Mifflin Reddit thread, and it listed several reasons why Bob Vance might be in the mafia. And I'm going to go through them. We also got mail from folks with ideas that I didn't see on the thread, and I checked those as well. So here's the theory. Bob Vance is actually in the mafia and just tried to sell himself as a fridge salesman in this documentary so he'd look like a legitimate business
但这是Reddit的链接。我很想听听你们对这个观点的看法，尤其是经过你们在黑手党那一集里对黑手党和斯克兰顿进行的那么多深入探讨之后。好吧，我去了这个Reddit帖子。它是当德米夫林Reddit板块的一部分，上面列出了鲍勃·范斯可能是黑手党成员的几个原因，我会一一盘点。我们也收到了来自其他朋友的邮件，他们提出了我在帖子上没看到的想法，我也核实了那些想法。所以这个理论是这样的：鲍勃·范斯实际上是黑手党成员，他只是在这个纪录片里把自己伪装成一个冰箱销售员，这样他在公众和可能对起疑心的警察面前看起来就像一个合法正当的企业。
in front of the public and the police who may be suspicious of him. And so begins the evidence, starting with a letter we got from Kelly B. in Annapolis, Maryland, who said, in crime aid, Bob doesn't even blink about bidding $1,000 to hug his wife. It's true. He's got some deep pockets. Yeah. Kelly also mentioned this talking head that was added to the Peacock superfan episode of Branch Closing. Listen to this. My fiancé, Bob Vance, he told me he'd give me a job at Vance Refrigeration. I'm called a senior advisor. I don't even have to come
证据就这样拉开了序幕，首先是我们收到来自马里兰州安纳波利斯的凯利·B.（Kelly B.）的信，她说，在“犯罪援助”（Crime Aid）里，鲍勃对于出价1000美元去拥抱他的妻子连眼睛都不眨一下。确实如此。他财大气粗。是的。凯利还提到了在《分公司关闭》（Branch Closing）的Peacock超级粉丝版中添加的一段采访（talking head）。听听这个。我的未婚夫，鲍勃·范斯，他告诉我说要在范斯冷气公司给我安排个工作。我头衔是高级顾问。我甚至都不用去
into work and I get paid in cash. Now that I say that out loud, it sounds illegal. I want you to know Phyllis smiles at the end of that. After she realizes it might be a little illegal, she smirks. Why is she smirking? I think she's kind of turned on by this idea that Bob Vance has some sort of operation going where he can pay cash. It might be illegal, but I think she's a little turned on by him breaking the rules. Oh, Phyllis.
上班就能拿现金薪水。现在我把话说出口，听起来这好像有点违法。我想让你们知道，菲利斯在那个片段结束时笑了。在她意识到这可能有点违法之后，她露出了得意的神情。她为什么要得意洋洋？我觉得她其实有点迷恋这种想法：鲍勃·范斯有某种能发现金的门路。这可能违法，但我认为她有点着迷于他打破规则的样子。哦，菲利斯。
That's what I took from it. Because you're going to see in these clips that Phyllis is often throwing around things Bob will do or won't do, okay? Okay, she's like muscle. She brags about it. Oh, she sure does. In fact, Kelly B points out that Phyllis has a talking head
这就是我的理解。因为你们会在这些片段中看到，菲利斯经常把鲍勃会做或不会做的事挂在嘴边，对吧？对，她就像是个打手。她以此吹嘘。哦，她当然吹嘘了。事实上，凯利·B指出菲利斯在第六季的《欢乐时光》（Happy Hour）里有一段采访，她在其中谈到和鲍勃·范斯一起外出时说：“我倾向于穿低胸装，让男人们来跟我调情，然后鲍勃就会痛扁他们。”而且，他们俩绝配。他们绝配。有好多集都暗示了鲍勃会用武力解决问题。哦，我懂。比如，当凯伦来到斯克兰顿，她甚至都不知道鲍勃·范斯是谁，
in season six, Happy Hour, where she talks about like going out with Bob Vance and she says, "'I tend to wear something low cut, "'get men to flirt with me and Bob beats them up. And again, they are twisted. They are twisted. There are a number of episodes that reference Bob muscling people. Oh, I know. For example, when Karen comes to Scranton and she doesn't even know who Bob Vance is,
她就问是谁？菲利斯告诉她，甜心，关于这个镇子，你还有很多要学的呢。凯伦来到斯克兰顿，她甚至都不知道鲍勃·范斯是谁。她就问是谁？菲利斯告诉她，甜心，关于这个镇子，你还有很多要学的呢。这里他说了算，姑娘。没错。还有《秘密圣诞老人》（Secret Santa）里的这个片段，菲利斯质问吉姆想当圣诞老人这事时怎么样？好吧，我在努力呢，菲利斯。
she's like who? Phyllis tells her you have a lot to learn about this town, sweetie. Karen comes to Scranton and she doesn't even know who Bob Vance is. She's like, who? Phyllis tells her you have a lot to learn about this town, sweetie. He runs the show, girl. Right. And how about this clip from Secret Santa when Phyllis confronts Jim about wanting to be Santa? Well, I'm trying Phyllis.
你是圣诞老人。唯一的圣诞老人。这就是我想要的。你答应过我的。别逼我把鲍勃牵扯进来。鲍勃会怎么做？算了。我不该说这话。显然他会打断你的双臂。
You're Santa. The only Santa. That's what I want. You promised me this. Don't make me get Bob involved. What would Bob do? Never mind. I shouldn't have said that. He'd break both your arms, apparently.
来自北卡罗来纳州目前住在夏威夷的凯特琳·S.（Caitlin S.）写信说：有一个被删掉的片段，安吉拉在《破产》（Broke）那一集里提到过，菲利斯在里面说：“你剥夺了我的福利，回头见鳄鱼（see you later alligator）。”那是指什么？听起来全是指代鲍勃。是的。现在我有了我认为可能是证明鲍勃·范斯属于黑手党的最有力的两条证据。
And Caitlin S. from North Carolina, who's currently living in Hawaii, wrote in to say, There's a deleted scene that Angela mentioned in the episode, Broke, where Phyllis says, You take away my perks, see you later alligator. What's that in reference to? It's all sounding like it's in reference to Bob. Yeah. And now I've got what I think are maybe my two most damning pieces of evidence that Bob Vance is in the mafia.
我一直在等一个。我要看看，这算不算其中之一。来自亚利桑那州梅萨的艾琳·O.（Erin O.）说，目前正在看第六季第六集《黑手党》（Mafia）的超级粉丝版，我们能聊聊菲利斯关于“FBI嫉妒鲍勃·范斯成功”的言论吗？黑手党成员都有一个幌子。有时是卖保险。有时是废物管理或环卫。对，很多罪犯通过合法企业来洗钱。我的意思是，鲍勃曾多次被指控，因为FBI嫉妒他的成功。FBI曾多次调查鲍勃涉嫌洗钱，因为他们嫉妒他的成功。
I've been waiting for one. I'm going to see, is it part of this. Erin Oh from Mesa, Arizona said currently watching the Superfan episodes on season 6 episode 6 Mafia, can we please talk about Phyllis's statement about the FBI being jealous of Bob Vance's success? Mobsters have a front. Sometimes it's selling insurance. Sometimes it's waste management or sanitation. Yeah, a lot of criminals launder money through a legitimate business. I mean, Bob has been accused several times because the FBI is jealous of his success. The FBI has investigated Bob several times for money laundering because they're jealous of his success.
范斯冷气公司的鲍勃·范斯。他们简直嫉妒死了。是的。是的。但现在我要带你们进入网络剧《爆发》（The Outburst）。哦，这是那个关于审判的网剧吧？对。对。
Bob Vance advanced refrigeration. They're like so jealous. Yeah. Yeah. But now I'm going to bring you to the web series, The Outburst. Oh, this is the one about the trial, right? Yep. Yep.
这就是我一直期待的。让我们听听。为什么大家就不能管好自己的事呢？当你在电话里大声说话，弄得所有人都知道了，奥斯卡。好吧，当办公室里所有人都在讨论鲍勃的大陪审团起诉书时，我可没去烦你，所以……他被宣判所有指控不成立。甚至没有一个证人出庭作证。一个都没有。这就是我一直期待的。大陪审团起诉了，然后没有一个证人出庭？
This is what I've been waiting for. Let's hear it. Why doesn't everyone just mind their own business? When you talk so loudly on your phone you made it everyone's business, Oscar. Okay, I didn't bother you when everybody in the office was talking about Bob's grand jury indictments, so... He was exonerated on all counts. None of the witnesses even showed up for the trial. None. That's the one I've been waiting for. There was a grand jury indictment and then none of the witnesses showed up?
对。这听起来太有黑手党的作风了。他们害怕了。他们不想跟鲍勃——斯克兰顿黑手党的老大作对。好吧，也许最大的一条证据来自于你的深入调查，安吉拉，关于斯克兰顿黑手党的调查，我猜它确实存在过。
Yeah. That's sounding very mafia-like to me. They were scared. They didn't want to go up against Bob, the head of the Scranton mafia. Well, I think perhaps the biggest piece of evidence comes from your deep dive, Angela, on the Scranton mafia. Well, I think perhaps the biggest piece of evidence comes from your deep dive, Angela, on the Scranton mafia, which I guess did exist.
现在还有吗？我们不知道。我们不知道。但它确实存在。我回去重新听了我们在《黑手党》那一集里的深入调查，我发现了一点我想指出来的地方。你提到了一个叫弗兰克·希兰（Frank Sheeran）的人。
Does it still? We don't know. We don't know. But it did. I went back and I re-listened to your deep dive from our episode mafia, and I found something I want to point out. You mentioned someone named Frank Sheeran.
他是个现实中的黑手党成员，被指控谋杀吉姆·霍法（Jimmy Hoffa）。他与罗素·巴法利诺（Russell Bufalino）有联系，后者是斯克兰顿的黑手党成员。所以这些都是真实存在的人物。是的。而在电影《爱尔兰人》（The Irishman）中，我们看到了这两个人是如何相遇的。现在，我不知道这是真的还是只是电影的一部分，但在电影中，希兰在一家加油站遇到汽车抛锚的巴法利诺，希兰帮他
He was a real mobster who was accused of killing Jimmy Hoffa. And he had links to Russell Bufalino, who was a Scranton mobster. So these are real people. Yes. And in the movie The Irishman, we see how these two people met. Now, I don't know if this is true or if this was just part of the movie, but in this movie, Sheeran meets Bufalino when his truck breaks down at a gas station and Sheeran helps him
修理了化油器。你猜斯克兰顿黑手党开的是什么卡车？冷藏车。答对了，答对了，答对了，答对了。他用它来运送肉类。他开的是冷藏车。难道他开的是一辆范斯冷气公司的卡车？难道这背后……
fix the carburetor. Guess what kind of truck the Scranton mobster was driving? A refrigeration truck. Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding. He used it to deliver meat. He drove a refrigeration truck. Could it be he was driving a Vance refrigeration truck? Does it go back?
我猜你存的东西可不止肉类。许多人指出，冷藏车是藏匿尸体的绝佳地方。我喜欢有这么多人在这方面进行侦探式搜证。有好多人。有好多人。这是我的侦探发现，因为我没看到其他人侦探出这一点。我想知道在《菲利斯的婚礼》（Phyllis's Wedding）那一集里是否有任何证据。我想，她办的是不是黑手党婚礼？比如，她的婚礼上会不会有证据？所以我查了查黑手党婚礼的元素。
I guess you can store more than just meat. Many people pointed out that refrigerated trucks are a great place to hide bodies. I love that there's several people sleuthing on this. So many. So many. Here was my sleuth because I didn't see anyone sleuth this. I wondered if there was any evidence in the episode, Phyllis's wedding. I was like, did she have a mob wedding? Like, would there be evidence in her wedding? So I looked up elements of a mob wedding.
我想你不仅可以储藏肉类。很多人指出冷藏卡车是藏尸的好地方。我喜欢有几个人在侦查这件事。非常多。非常多。我的侦查是这样的，因为我没看到任何人侦查这个。我想知道在这集《菲yllis的婚礼》中是否有任何证据。我在想，她举行的是黑帮婚礼吗？也就是说，她的婚礼上会有证据吗？所以我查了一下黑帮婚礼的元素。
Like, how have they been portrayed in other movies and things? And were there any similarities? There is an over-the-top wedding cake with a refrigerator on top of it. Well, that's on my list. OK. In The Godfather, we meet Don Corleone played
比如，他们在其他电影之类的作品里是怎么被刻画的？有什么相似之处吗？有一个顶上带有冰箱的夸张结婚蛋糕。好吧，这在我的清单上。好吧。在《教父》中，我们见到了由马龙·白兰度饰演的
by Marlon Brando at the wedding of his daughter. This is also where we are introduced to the entire Corleone crime family. There's also a wedding scene in the movie Goodfellas and in Casino, so I watched all of these wedding scenes and I took notes and I compared them to Phyllis's wedding. One note, in The Godfather movie they introduce this idea that a mob boss cannot refuse a request on the day of his daughter's wedding. This is not true. It was made up for the movie. It's kind of like considered a little bit of a scandal because in general, the film was very intentional about trying to stay true to the specifics of the Sicilian mafia. But this was made up. They missed that one. They did. But here are the things that I observed that were at both a mob wedding
唐·柯里昂，当时正值他女儿的婚礼。这也是我们整个柯里昂犯罪家族的初次登场。电影《好家伙》和《赌城风云》中也有婚礼场景，所以我看了所有这些婚礼场景，做了笔记，并把它们和菲莉丝的婚礼进行了对比。有一个笔记是，在《教父》电影中引入了一个观点，即黑帮老大在女儿婚礼当天不能拒绝任何请求。这不是真的。这是为了电影虚构的。这有点被认为是一个小丑闻，因为总的来说，这部电影在努力忠实于西西里黑手党的细节方面非常有心。但这是虚构的。他们漏掉了这一点。确实漏了。但以下是我观察到的既出现在黑帮婚礼上
and Phyllis's wedding. And I only went with things that all these weddings had in common. This was not a comparison I thought I'd hear today. There it is. I'm very excited about it. Very large weddings, all of them. OK, lots of guests. OK. Lots of guests. OK. Big, big wedding.
又出现在菲莉丝婚礼上的东西。我只挑选了所有这些婚礼共同具备的东西。我没想到今天会听到这样的对比。就是这样。我对此感到非常兴奋。非常盛大的婚礼，全都是这样。好吧，有很多客人。好吧。有很多客人。好吧。盛大、盛大的婚礼。
Yes, but also very large bridal parties. OK. All of these weddings. So many bridesmaids and bridesmaids dresses. Giant cake. Yeah. Live music, maybe with a celebrity singer. Is Kevin a local celebrity?
是的，而且伴郎伴娘团也非常庞大。好吧。所有这些婚礼。有那么多的伴娘和伴娘礼服。巨大的蛋糕。是的。现场音乐，也许还有明星歌手。凯文是当地名人吗？
I don't know. Maybe that's a stretch. But live music. There's no DJs at any of these weddings. Lavish. Very lavish. Throwing around your wealth. Large, lavish.
我不知道。也许这有点牵强。但有现场音乐。所有这些婚礼上都没有DJ。奢华。非常奢华。挥金如土。盛大、奢华。
You got another L for me. Live music. Oh, live. Yeah. Okay. All the L's. Large, live music Yeah. OK. All the L. Large live music lavish. Now, in Goodfellas, the bride sits in a chair, and there's this receiving line of people
你又给我出了一个L开头的词。现场音乐。哦，现场。是的。好吧。所有的L开头的词。盛大、现场音乐。是的。好吧。所有的L。盛大、现场音乐、奢华。现在，在《好家伙》中，新娘坐在椅子上，有一排人
that walk up and just give her envelopes of cash. That did not happen to Phyllis. That we know of. That we saw in the documentary. But I watched the super fan of Phyllis's wedding. I wanted to see all the footage that was now included in the documentary, but I watched the super fan of Phyllis's wedding. I wanted to see all the footage that was now included in the canon. And I did see this moment, which is in all episodes. This is when Michael is in the receiving line and he gets to Bob Vance and they have this exchange. Listen to this. Congratulations, Bob. You're a good man. Just know if you ever lay a finger
走过来，直接递给她一封封现金信封。菲莉丝可没遇到这种事。据我们所知。我们在纪录片里看到的。但我看了菲莉丝婚礼的超级粉丝版。我想看看现在被收录进纪录片里的所有素材，但我看了菲莉丝婚礼的超级粉丝版。我想看看现在被收录进正片里的所有素材。我的确看到了这一幕，这一幕在所有剧集里都有。这就是迈克尔在迎宾队伍中，他来到鲍勃·万斯面前，两人有这样一段对话。听听这个。恭喜你，鲍勃。你是个好人。只要记住，如果你敢动菲莉丝一根手指头
on Phyllis, I will kill you. If you ever lay a finger on Phyllis, I will kill you. If you ever lay a finger on Phyllis, I'll kill you. Agreed. No fingers will be laid on Phyllis. Hmm. He seemed very comfortable making that threat. I mean, so did Michael, but... No, I don't know.
我就会杀了你。如果你敢动菲莉丝一根手指头，我就会杀了你。如果你敢动菲莉丝一根手指头，我就会杀了你。成交。不会有人动菲莉丝一根手指头的。嗯。他发出那个威胁时显得非常自在。我的意思是，迈克尔也是，但是……不，我不知道。
If you see, if you see the scene I know he's got a gravity to him when he says Bob Vance. Mm-hmm. So I don't know. What do you think? Do we think? That Bob Vance is in the mafia is Vance refrigeration a front. Is it just a money laundering operation? Well, look, I think he's definitely into some shady business. Okay. I say he's into shady business. Sam?
如果你看，如果你看到那个场景，我知道当他说“鲍勃·万斯”时，他有一种威严感。嗯哼。所以，我不知道。你们怎么想？我们觉得呢？鲍勃·万斯在黑手党里吗？万斯制冷公司是个幌子吗？它只是一个洗钱行动吗？嗯，听着，我觉得他绝对参与了一些见不得光的勾当。好吧。我说他参与了见不得光的勾当。萨姆？
I could see the money laundering thing. Okay. Yeah, definitely illegal activity, but I think if he was in the mafia, Phyllis wouldn't work. I think she would be a mafia liar. A liability. Yeah. And also, I feel like Michael would know and it would just be bad. He'd have to take out too many Dunder Mifflin employees. Okay. I like what you're saying about Phyllis here. I hear that. Like why do they want to
我能理解洗钱这种说法。好吧。是的，绝对是非法活动，但我觉得如果他在黑手党里，菲莉丝就不会工作了。我觉得她会成为黑手党的累赘。一个软肋。是的。而且，我觉得迈克尔会知道，那样事情就会变得很糟。他得干掉太多邓德米夫林的员工了。好吧。我喜欢你刚才对菲莉丝的评价。我听进去了。比如他们为什么想要
have to file with the IRS? Yeah. She wouldn't have her job anymore. Yeah. Yeah. But he's up to some shady business. It doesn't seem like she needs her job, but she does continue to work. She must like it, I guess. I think she does.
向美国国税局报税？是的。她就不能再有工作了。是的。是的。但他确实在搞一些见不得光的勾当。看起来她并不需要这份工作，但她确实一直在工作。我想她一定是喜欢这份工作。我觉得她是喜欢。
In some capacity. We should dive into that in all about Phyllis Lapin. I think she likes her job. I do too. Well, finally, Bobby Ray Schaefer did an interview with cracked.com last December, and they asked him about this. They said the online fandom has some crazy theories about Bob. Some think he's in the mafia. What do you think? So here is from Bob Vance himself. Bobby Ray Schaefer said,
在某种程度上。我们应该在“关于菲莉丝·拉平”那一期里深入探讨一下。我觉得她喜欢自己的工作。我也这么觉得。好吧，最后，鲍比·雷·谢弗去年12月接受了cracked.com的采访，他们问了他这件事。他们说网络粉丝对鲍勃有一些疯狂的理论。有人认为他在黑手党里。你怎么看？所以这是鲍勃·万斯本人说的。鲍比·雷·谢弗说，
maybe something fell off a truck here or there. Who knows? I never played that though. So it was never part of his backstory. He was not ever playing this. He was never told to play it or directed to play it. I like that. I like maybe something fell off the truck every once in a while. Yeah. You know, I think in my neighborhood,
也许这儿或那儿有什么东西从卡车上掉下来了。谁知道呢？不过我从来没那样演过。所以这从来都不是他背景故事的一部分。他从来没有这样演过，也从来没有人告诉他要这么演或指导他这么演。我喜欢那样。我喜欢“偶尔有什么东西从卡车上掉下来”这种说法。是的。你知道，我觉得在我附近，
there's a business we wonder about. This isn't the building with no windows because we got to the bottom of that. Now we mom detected of that. This is a chocolate shop. You think it's a front? It's a chocolate and flower shop. And I took my kids and my niece and nephew in there many summers ago. And the chocolate was like so expensive.
有一家店让我们很好奇。这不是那栋没有窗户的建筑，因为我们已经把那件事弄个水落石出了。我们已经对那件事进行了“妈妈侦探”式的调查。这是一间巧克力店。你觉得这是个幌子？这是一家巧克力和鲜花店。好几个夏天前，我和我的孩子们还有我外甥、外甥女一起进去过。那里的巧克力简直贵得离谱。
It was like, I've never seen chocolate at this price. And the flowers were, I don't know. I just, we all, we left with no chocolate. I was like, I'm sorry, this is the most expensive chocolate on earth. They didn't seem sad to lose our business. I was like, what are you selling in here? Because you're not, who's buying this chocolate?
就像，我从来没见过这个价位的巧克力。至于鲜花，我不知道。总之，我们，我们离开时没有买巧克力。我说，对不起，这是地球上最贵的巧克力。他们似乎并不为失去我们的生意而难过。我说，你们这里到底在卖什么？因为你们卖的不是，谁会买这种巧克力？
Yeah, okay, so we have a thing like this in our family too. There's this little tiny little mini mall that we drive by on a regular basis. And I don't know if it's because we've been watching Ozark and so now we're like, everything's up front. Yes, yes, it's a money laundering front. But the businesses in this little mini mall are like some kind of yoga studio and then a hair removal and then a psychic. No one's ever parked in the parking lot ever. They're constantly doing
好吧，好吧，我们家里也有类似的情况。我们经常开车路过一个小小的迷你购物中心。我不知道是不是因为我们一直在看《黑钱胜地》，所以现在我们觉得，所有事情都是个幌子。是的，是的，它是个洗钱的幌子。但这个小迷你购物中心里的生意就像是什么瑜伽工作室，然后是脱毛中心，然后是灵媒。停车场里从来没有人停过车。他们一直在对大楼
work to the building. They just put all this tile in the front to make it look like a waterfall. I'm like, that's expensive, tiny little crystal tiles. I'm like, this is a front, this is a front. No one's going there. This chocolate shop is in a little mini mall as well. Right? Yeah. We talk about it all the time. We never see people going in and out.
进行施工。他们刚刚在正面铺了所有这些瓷砖，让它看起来像个瀑布。我想，那太贵了，小小的水晶瓷砖。我想，这是个幌子，这是个幌子。根本没有人去那儿。这家巧克力店也在一个小迷你购物中心里。对吧？是的。我们一直在讨论它。我们从来没看到有人进进出出。
Yeah. It opens, but for weird times. It never looks opened. You can't park there. And I was like, Josh, we need to sign up for like one of the yoga classes to see our... I'll go with you. Go get a consult for hair removal or something to see. Lady, this is our next mom detectives.
是的。它开门，但营业时间很奇怪。它看起来从来都不营业。你没法在那里停车。我说，乔什，我们需要报名参加比如其中一个瑜伽班，去看看我们的……我和你一起去。去咨询一下脱毛什么的看看。女士们，这就是我们的下一个“妈妈侦探”目标。
I will sign up for a yoga class in that strip mall with you, and I need you to come try to buy some chocolate with me. Okay. We're gonna get to the bottom of it. Let's do it. This has opened a whole new mom detective moment. I wasn't expecting. All right, well everyone, that is the fan theory is Bob Vance in the Scranton Mafia. Angela, I'm sure you'll put a poll in stories so you all can weigh in. Mm-hmm. Why don't we take a break and we'll find out if the offices really help. ["The Office is Hell"] When you let aerotruffle bubbles melt,
我会和你一起去那个商业街的瑜伽班报名，而我需要你和我一起去试着买点巧克力。好吧。我们要把它查个水落石出。干吧。这开启了一个我意想不到的全新的“妈妈侦探”时刻。好吧，各位，这就是关于“鲍勃·万斯是否在斯克兰顿黑手党”的粉丝理论。安吉拉，我确信你会在动态里发起一个投票，好让大家都能发表意见。嗯哼。我们为什么不休息一下，看看办公室到底是不是地狱。《办公室就是地狱》当你想让阿罗黑松露气泡融化时，
everything takes on a creamy, delicious, chocolatey glow. Like that pile of laundry. You didn't forget to fold it. No, it's a new trend. Wrinkled chic. Feel the aero bubbles melt. It's mind-bubbling. Are you crushing your bills? Defeating your monthly payments. Sounds like you're at the top of your financial game. Rise to it with the BMO Eclipse Rise Visa Card. The credit card that rewards your good financial
一切都会带有一种奶油般美味的、巧克力般的微光。就像那堆衣服。你没有忘记叠它。不，这是一种新潮流。褶皱风。感受阿罗气泡融化。这简直是脑洞大开。你在为账单焦头烂额吗？在为每月的付款发愁吗？听起来你正处于财务状况的最佳状态。使用BMO优势理财Visa卡来提升自己。这张信用卡能奖励你良好的财务
habits. Earn points for paying your credit card that rewards your good financial habits. Earn points for paying your credit card bill in full and on time every month. Level up from bill payer to reward slayer. Terms and conditions apply. This Friday, the amateur of Rives and IMAX. I want to find and kill the people who murdered my wife. Critics rave the amateur is a tense, unpredictable ride. You're just not a killer, Charlie.
习惯。每个月全额且按时支付信用卡账单即可赚取积分。从账单支付者升级为奖励收割者。须遵守条款和条件。本周五，IMAX上映《业余杀手》。我要找到并杀死谋杀我妻子的凶手。评论界盛赞《业余杀手》是一场紧张、不可预测的惊险之旅。你根本不是个杀手，查理。
Train me. That constantly finds new and inventive ways to up the stakes. The first one you kill, you let the other ones know you're coming. You don't want them all? Academy Award winner Rummy Malik and Academy Award nominee Lawrence Fishburne, The Amateur.
训练我。它不断寻找新的、有创意的方式来提高赌注。你杀的第一个人，会让其他人知道你要来了。你不想把他们一网打尽吗？奥斯卡奖得主拉米·马雷克和奥斯卡奖提名者劳伦斯·菲什伯恩主演，《业余杀手》。
Only in theaters on IMAX Friday. Get tickets now. Welcome back to Office Ladies 6.0 and to my fan theory that well it's a it's a journey y'all it's a journey. It all started when I was googling the office fan theories. I was a lady who Googled. All right. As we do. And I came across this article on mentalfloss.com in September of 2022.
本周五仅在IMAX影院上映。立即购票。欢迎回到《办公室女士》6.0版，欢迎来到我的粉丝理论——好吧，这是一场旅程，各位，这是一场旅程。这一切都始于我在谷歌上搜索《办公室》的粉丝理论。我是一个喜欢谷歌搜索的女士。没错。正如我们所做的那样。我在2022年9月的mentalfloss.com上偶然发现了这篇文章。
It was titled, 12 Compelling Fan Theories About the Office. And number seven was listed as, The Office is Actually Hell. And I was like, what? Come on. That's crazy. as the office is actually hell. And I was like, what? Come on, that's crazy. Also, I have to ask you a quick question because when I was growing up,
它的标题是《关于〈办公室〉的12个令人信服的粉丝理论》。第七条列出的是：《办公室》其实就是地狱。当时我就想，什么？拜托。太疯狂了。作为《办公室》其实就是地狱。当时我就想，什么？拜托，太疯狂了。另外，我得问你一个简单的问题，因为在我长大的时候，
like hell was like a curse word. I mean, I know it's not anymore, really. Sure, I mean, you'd have to say H-E double hockey sticks. That's what we said. We would say what in the H-E double hockey sticks is going on. Yeah. Do people still what in the H-E double hockey sticks is going on. Do people still say that? H-E double hockey sticks? Probably.
比如“地狱”（hell）就像是一个脏话。我的意思是，我知道现在真的不是了。当然，我的意思是，你得说“H-E双冰球棍”。我们当时就是这么说的。我们会说“这到底（H-E双冰球棍）是怎么回事”。是的。人们还会说“这到底（H-E双冰球棍）是怎么回事”吗？人们还会这么说吗？H-E双冰球棍？可能吧。
I don't think so. Somewhere. But I'm not sure. I think somewhere. I think somewhere people are still saying it. Or you know another one we would do? You'd be like, what the hell is going on? Oh, that's a good one.
我不这么觉得。在某个地方。但我不是很确定。我想在某个地方。我想在某些地方人们仍然在这么说。或者你知道我们还会用的另一个词吗？你会说，到底（what the hell）是怎么回事？哦，这是个好词。
You'd like return it into something else, but you get it in there. Right. Like saying shut the front door. else. Yes. But you get it in there. Right. Like saying, shut the front door. Exactly. Exactly. See you next Tuesday. That's a real... Oh, oh, oh!
你会把它变成别的什么，但你还是表达了那个意思。没错。就像说“闭上你的前门”一样。别的。是的。但你还是表达了那个意思。没错。就像说，闭上你的前门。完全正确。完全正确。下周二见。那可真是个——哦，哦，哦！
Angela! Angela! What? I didn't come up with it. My friend's mom said that one time and we all about fell out of our chairs. Jenna, is this your first time hearing that? I, I, I, you know what? I've heard that phrase before and I am Angela today because I never put it together.
安吉拉！安吉拉！干嘛？又不是我想出来的。我朋友的妈妈有一次那么说过，我们所有人都差点从椅子上笑翻过去。珍娜，这是你第一次听到这个说法吗？我，我，我，你知道吗？我以前听过这个短语，我今天就是安吉拉，因为我从来没把它们联系在一起。
And I am worried now that I have said that. Just thinking when I'm saying that, that what I'm saying is that that person is just someone I don't want to see for a long time. I'm going to see you next Tuesday. Right, like how I thought the sloppy thing was about leftovers. We've not ever told that story, Angela, and I don't know if you want to go there now or not. Oh, no. I don't even know if we should. I think we can save it.
我现在甚至有点担心我刚才说过的话了。只要一想到当我这么说的时候，我所表达的意思其实是那个人只是我不想见很久的人。我下周二见你。没错，就像我以前以为“sloppy”这个词是指剩菜一样。我们从来没讲过那个故事，安吉拉，我不知道你现在还想不想提它。哦，不。我甚至不知道我们应不应该提。我觉得我们可以保留它。
It's a horrible phrase that for years I have thought meant you were just really sloppy at something. Like maybe, or you used your leftovers. Anyway, I thought it was like a food reference. It's not. It's not. And I said it one time in front of you guys. The phrase is sloppy seconds. And I said it. I don't want that person's sloppy seconds. That's right, cause I don't want their messy leftovers.
这是一个可怕的短语，多年来我一直以为它指的是你在某事上真的很马虎。比如可能，或者你用了你的剩菜。不管怎样，我以为这是一个关于食物的代指。根本不是。根本不是。我有一次在你们面前说过了。那个短语是“sloppy seconds”（二手货/残羹冷炙）。然后我就说出来了。我才不要那个人的二手货呢。没错，因为我不想要他们那些乱七八糟的剩菜。
Right. And I said that to you guys and you were- And we were like, what? What? And you were so, like, taken aback. And I was like, what are you talking about? That is one of the most crass things you've ever said, Angela.
没错。然后我对你们这么说了，你们就——而我们当时的反应是：什么？什么？而你当时是那样的，就好像受到了惊吓。然后我就说，你们在说什么？那是你说过最粗俗的话之一了，安吉拉。
And I was like, I don't want your leftovers. And then you were so innocent. And then I was horrified. And then you were viraled because you realized you have said that. I think I have. I think I said it one time, like at a parent meeting. I think I said, well, no one wants those sloppy seconds. I think-
然后我说，我才不要你们的剩菜呢。然后你表现得那么天真。然后我吓坏了。然后你整个人都不好了，因为你意识到你说了那个词。我想我是说过。我想我有一次在家长会上说过。我想我说过，嗯，没人想要那些二手货。我想——
I think that's insane. That's insane. I've replayed that parent teacher meeting. I'm like, oh my gosh. It was like years ago. I don't know. Maybe I've said it other places. Well, there is a chance that I've said,
我觉得这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。我一直在脑海里回放那个家长会。我心想，哦天哪。那是好几年前的事了。我不知道。也许我在其他地方也说过。好吧，我还是有可能会说，
See you. See you next Tuesday. Cause it just went off, it just connected for me. The light bulb. Anyway, we are ladies that don't know phrases. We should maybe Google more. I don't wanna Google that one that I thought was leftovers ever.
再见。下周二见。因为刚才它突然，我一下子就串联起来了。灵光一现。不管怎样，我们俩都是对俚语一无所知的女士。我们也许应该多用谷歌搜索一下。我再也不想去谷歌搜索那个我以为是剩菜的词了。
No, do not. No. Do not, because it is a very... I don't want to talk about it. I'm embarrassed about it. I can't believe I didn't understand what it was. Well, I want to warn people to not Google it if they don't want to be offended. It is a reference that, how can I explain it without an E?
不，千万别。不。千万别，因为它是一个非常——我不想谈论它。我对此感到很尴尬。我真不敢相信我当时不明白它是什么意思。好吧，我想警告大家，如果不想被冒犯的话，千万不要去谷歌搜索它。这是一个代指，我怎么在没有E字母的情况下解释它呢？
It's just really bad. It's bad. It's just bad. And it's a very misogynistic term. And it is not at all about leftover food or being a sloppy person, which is what I thought it was. Yeah. I'm still horrified by that.
它真的很糟糕。很糟糕。就是很糟糕。这是一个非常厌女的词。它根本跟剩菜或者做事马虎没有任何关系，而我以前居然一直是这么以为的。是的。我至今仍对此感到震惊。
Okay, okay, well there, we have finally discussed it. It's something that everyone here for y'all listening, it was maybe like an afternoon where you guys completely lost it. Okay, all right. Where was I? Okay, H.E. Double Hockey Sticks. Yes, hell is the office hell.
好吧，好吧，好吧，我们终于讨论过这事了。对于所有在听的各位来说，这大概就像是一个你们彻底笑疯了的下午吧。好吧，好吧。我刚才讲到哪儿了？好吧，H-E双冰球棍。是的，地狱，办公室就是地狱吗？
Is the office, well, let's put it in the terms of how we grew up. Is the office actually H.E. Double Hockey Sticks? Okay, I know it's out there. It's out there. What is it? Well, you know, listen, I have had some really boring monotonous jobs, especially when I was temping,
办公室，嗯，让我们用我们成长时的说法来表达。办公室真的就是H-E双冰球棍吗？好吧，我知道这有点离谱。这确实很离谱。到底是什么？嗯，你知道，听吧，我以前做过一些非常无聊单调的工作，特别是在我做临时工的时候，
that felt like a form of maybe purgatory. Okay. So I was curious, maybe this fan theory is talking about those places you get stuck in. And maybe Dunder Mifflin is something like that. Okay, okay, I'm hearing it. I was curious. This is what the article said in MentalFloss.com. Quote, a bunch of people sincerely believe that the Scranton office is hell, but that it didn't become a hellscape until after one key episode. What episode? Lady, I couldn't believe this. Stress relief. The one where Dwight starts the fire in
感觉就像是一种炼狱。好吧。所以我很好奇，也许这个粉丝理论讨论的就是那些让你深陷其中的地方。也许邓德米夫林就是那样的地方。好吧，好吧，我听懂了。我很好奇。这就是MentalFloss.com文章里说的。原话是：“很多人真心相信斯克兰顿办公室就是地狱，但它直到经历了关键的一集之后才真正变成人间炼狱。”哪一集？天哪，我简直不敢相信。《压力缓解》。德怀特在
the office? Yes. Well, here's what the article says. In the first part of stress relief, Stanley has a heart attack in the middle of the safety drill. Yes. Right? Yes. And Stanley survives and then he has to return to work. The theory says, what if Stanley really died that day? Huh? And then what? So the theory goes, Stanley's heart attack kills him and he goes to the bad place. And the bad place for him is Dunder Mifflin.
办公室里放火的那集？是的。嗯，文章是这么说的。《压力缓解》的第一部分中，斯坦利在安全演习期间心脏病发作。是的。对吧？是的。斯坦利活了下来，然后他不得不重返工作岗位。这个理论说，如果斯坦利那天真的死了呢？啊？然后呢？所以这个理论认为，斯坦利的心脏病发作要了他的命，他去了坏地方。对他来说，坏地方就是邓德米夫林。
Well, that does make me laugh. I mean- That would be Stanley's hell. It wouldn't it? Having to endure working at Dunder Mifflin. He wants to retire so desperately. Oh Stanley. He can't wait to get out of there at five o'clock every day. I mean all that man wants is a bubble bath and a glass of red wine. That's it. Well this article made me curious about this theory. I wondered what other office
嗯，这确实让我笑出声来。我的意思是——那将是斯坦利的炼狱。难道不是吗？不得不忍受在邓德米夫林工作。他太渴望退休了。哦，斯坦利。他每天一到五点就迫不及待地想离开那里。我的意思是，那家伙想要的全部就是一次泡泡浴和一杯红酒。就这些。好吧，这篇文章让我对这个理论产生了好奇。我想知道其他《办公室》的
fans thought and I dug a little deeper and I think I found what was the original post about it that started it all. Okay. It was 10 years ago, way before the Mental Floss article. Okay. And basically, an Office fan kind of came up with this theory because they felt like the show took a nosedive after stress relief. Wait.
粉丝是怎么想的，于是我深入挖掘了一下，我觉得我找到了最初发布这个理论、也就是一切起源的帖子。好吧。那是10年前的事了，远在MentalFloss的文章发表之前。好吧。基本上，一个《办公室》的粉丝提出了这个理论，因为他们觉得这部剧在《压力缓解》之后就呈断崖式下跌。等等。
So, this theory is based on the fact that they just didn't like any episodes from that point on? Yes, they said the show kind of became cartoonish. The characters got more exaggerated and broad. And I think the theory that Dunder Mifflin is Stanley's hell that is kind of funny. Yes, I can see that. Have you seen that thing on Instagram where people post their's hell, that is kind of funny. Yes, I can see that. Have you seen that thing on Instagram
所以，这个理论是基于他们只是不喜欢从那以后播出的任何一集的事实吗？是的，他们说这部剧变得有点像动画片了。角色变得更加夸张和脸谱化。而且我觉得“邓德米夫林是斯坦利的炼狱”这个理论还蛮搞笑的。是的，我能理解。你在Instagram上见过那种大家发帖说自己的个人炼狱是什么的地方吗？——如果是斯坦利的炼狱，那还蛮搞笑的。是的，我能理解。你在Instagram上见过那种
where people post their personal hell? Like some person is like, my personal hell is having to spend eternity figuring out what's for dinner every night. That's so funny because it is, that is something that drives Josh crazy. He's always like, what are we having for dinner tonight? Because he's such a planner.
大家发帖说自己的个人炼狱是什么的地方吗？就像有个人说，我的个人炼狱是每个世纪都要花时间琢磨每天晚上晚饭吃什么。太搞笑了，因为确实如此，这正是让乔什抓狂的事。他总是问：“我们今晚晚饭吃什么？”因为他是个超级计划通。
Yes, yes. Well, this did lead me down the rabbit hole. And there are some funny theories about characters on The Office that might be the devil. Oh. For example, Toby. They're like, is Toby the devil? Because he drives Michael so crazy.
是的，是的。好吧，这确实让我陷入了沉思。关于《办公室》里可能谁是魔鬼的角色，还有一些有趣的理论。哦。比如，托比。他们会问，托比是魔鬼吗？因为他把迈克尔逼得快疯了。
Is he Satan? Who is Toby? I know. He's the Scranton Strangler. He's the devil. Everybody, he's just Toby. Everyone dumps on Toby. Toby is just Toby, that's what someone wrote in and said.
他是撒旦吗？托比到底是谁？我知道。他是斯克兰顿扼喉手。他是魔鬼。各位，他只是托比。所有人都把气撒在托比身上。托比就只是托比，这就是某个网友发信来说的。
Well, there is another one that Michael's Hill might just be living in the condo with Jan. Oh, like dinner party? Yeah, I mean, you remember this moment? I'm so, so sorry for the temperature in here. The sliding glass door shattered. It's actually a really cute story. Do you want to tell it babe or should I tell it?
嗯，还有另一个理论说，迈克尔的地狱可能就是和简一起住在公寓里。哦，就像晚宴那一集？是的，我的意思是，你还记得这个时刻吗？对于这里的温度，我感到非常非常抱歉。那扇推拉门碎了。其实这是一个非常可爱的小故事。你想讲讲吗，宝贝，还是我来讲？
I don't like that story babe. Come on, it's a cute story. Michael ran through the sliding glass door because he thought he heard the ice cream truck. Stop, stop it. I mean he heard the ice cream truck. Stop! Stop it! I mean, I like ice cream, okay?
我可不喜欢那个故事，宝贝。拜托，这是个可爱的故事。迈克尔直接撞穿了推拉门，因为他以为他听到冰淇淋车的声音了。够了，别说了！我的意思是，他听到冰淇淋车的声音了。够了！别说了！我的意思是，我喜欢冰淇淋，好吧？
Sue me. Oh, no, don't. I shouldn't say that jokingly because she will sue me. She loves to sue. She loves lawsuits. You know, honey, that door was extremely clean and it looked invisible. You are so right. You are so right because before I lived here,
告我啊。哦，不，别。我不该开玩笑说这话，因为她真的会告我。她太喜欢起诉了。她热爱诉讼。你知道的，亲爱的，那扇门极其干净，看起来就像是隐形的一样。你说的太对了。你说的太对了，因为在我住进来之前，
the glass was always covered in smudges. And I moved in and I cleaned it. So I guess that makes me the devil. Oh, you are. She is. She is the devil. I'm in hell. Ah, I'm hurting.
玻璃上总是沾满污渍。我搬进来后把它擦干净了。所以我想这让我成了魔鬼。哦，你确实是。她就是。她就是魔鬼。我在地狱里。啊，我好痛。
Help me. You shouldn't joke about that. Is there more wine in the kitchen? I will get it. I will get it. I love that Pam's response to all that is that she'd like another glass of wine. Lady, if I had to think what my personal hell is,
救救我。你不该拿这个开玩笑。厨房里还有酒吗？我去拿。我去拿。我太喜欢潘对这一切的反应了，那就是她想要再喝一杯酒。女士们，如果我必须想想我个人的炼狱是什么，
it might be this dinner party, truly. To imagine as an introvert where for all of eternity I have to go to a dinner party that they haven't served me any food after 40 minutes. Cause I'm done socializing now at 40 minutes in. Oh, small talk, no food. So much small talk. Cringy dramatic moment that you have to then sit through. Also like an obligated dinner party,
那大概真的就是这个晚宴了。作为一个内向的人，想象一下我要在永恒的时光里去参加一个晚宴，而他们在40分钟后都还没给我上任何食物。因为我在40分钟的时候就已经社交结束了。哦，闲聊，没有食物。那么多的闲聊。还有你不得不熬过去的尴尬抓马时刻。还有那种被迫参加的晚宴，
not with my actual friends, but like something that I've been obligated to go to and sit through that is going on forever. Yeah. Yeah. That could be mine. Yeah. Sam, Cassie, do you have a personal hell moment?
不是跟我真正的朋友，而是某种我不得不去并硬着头皮坐完整场的晚宴，而且它还永远不会结束。对。对。那可能就是我的个人炼狱。对。萨姆，卡西，你们有什么个人炼狱时刻吗？
Every six months, we have to call our internet because the internet bill goes up and we have to pretend that we're leaving and be like, we need to talk to retention. Retention? Yeah. That's a department? That's a department and you act like you're leaving and then they'll lower your bill back to the rate, but every six months we have to do it
每六个月，我们就得给宽带公司打电话，因为网费上涨了，然后我们得假装我们要换运营商，说：“我们需要和客户保留部门谈谈。”保留部门？对。还有这个部门？有这个部门，你得假装你要取消业务，然后他们就会把你的网费降回原来的标准，但每六个月我们就得这么做一次，
and it drives me nuts. Why are they raising it every six months? Because it's bad internet monopolies being evil. Yes. A retention department. What does it say about my personality that I would look forward to that call every six months? Jenna, do you want to do it for us every six months? I mean, maybe. You just signed up to talk to the retention department.
这快把我逼疯了。为什么他们每六个月就要涨一次价？因为这是糟糕的网络垄断企业在作恶。是的。客户保留部门。这说明我的性格有什么问题呢？我居然会期待每六个月打一次这个电话。珍娜，你想每六个月帮我们打一次吗？我的意思是，也许吧。你刚刚主动申请去和客户保留部门通话了。
I don't know. Sam? I would say mine would be permanently trapped on a bad date with someone not asking anything about you, just talking at you. Oh, yeah. That's no fun. Oh, Sam, have you had one of those lately? Yes, I have.
我不知道。萨姆？我会说我的个人炼狱是永远被困在一次糟糕的约会中，对方什么都不问你，只是单方面对你喋喋不休。哦，对。那可太没意思了。哦，萨姆，你最近经历过这种事吗？是的，我有。
Oh, no, no. That's a fresh memory. It felt fresh. Angela, what about you? You know, I thought about this when I was researching this fan theory and mine is so specific. But you know when you're traveling somewhere and you're sort of in a confined space. I don't know, the shuttle to the airport, train, bus as a plane, just that confined space. One time I was on a bus and there was a woman sitting behind me and it was like a two
哦，不，不。那可真是个新鲜的记忆。感觉记忆犹新。安吉拉，你呢？你知道的，我在研究这个粉丝理论时想过这个问题，我的那个特别具体。但你知道当你去某地旅行时，你有点身处一个密闭空间里。我不知道，去机场的穿梭巴士、火车、公交车或是飞机，就是那种密闭空间。有一次我坐公交车，我后面坐着一个女人，那是一趟大约两个
hour bus ride and she had a water bottle that she kept doing this to. I brought this prop in special so I could do this. She did it for two hours. This sound and I'm sorry for y'all listening, I thought, I'm gonna lose it. This is horrible. If this ride was any longer, I don't know what I'd do. I might turn around and just grab it and throw it out the window. Please.
小时的公交车程，她手里拿着一个水瓶，一直在不停地做这个动作。我专门带了这个道具来，这样我就可以演示了。她做了整整两个小时。这个声音，对于正在收听的各位我很抱歉，我想，我快要疯了。这太可怕了。如果这趟车程再长一点，我都不知道自己会做出什么来。我可能会转过身去一把抢过它然后扔出窗外。求你了。
Wow. Your personal hell is so simple and specific. It really is. It's not layered with anything else. No. Do not crunch a water bottle or like if you have a wrapper behind me.
哇。你的个人炼狱居然这么简单又具体。确实如此。里面没有任何复杂的层次。没有。千万不要捏响水瓶，或者如果你在我身后发出包装纸的声响……
It's very, it's like an ASMR thing for you. I guess so. But yeah, that would be it for me. That would be my bad place. So that is that fan theory. It did lead me to some other interesting articles. There are several lists of like characters that make the worst list.
这有点像你的ASMR克星。我想是的。不过是的，对这就是我。那会是我的坏地方。所以这就是那个粉丝理论。它确实引导我去看了一些其他有趣的文章。有几个关于“最差角色”排行榜的列表。
Okay. Meaning they're horrible people? Horrible people, yeah. From the office characters. That's right. Can I guess who they are? Well, there's one on Screen Rant lists the top five baddies of the office and lists reasons why they're so horrible. All right. Robert California.
好吧。意思是他们是糟糕透顶的人？糟糕透顶的人，是的。来自《办公室》的角色。没错。我能猜到他们是谁吗？嗯，Screen Rant网站上有一个榜单，列出了办公室里的前五名恶人，并列出了他们为什么这么糟糕的原因。好吧。罗伯特·加利福尼亚。
Not on the list. What? This list has lost all credibility already. I won't read the rest of it. Well, I am curious, Ryan Howard, is he on the list? Number one. Well, thankfully that is happening, okay. I don't know.
没上榜。什么？这个榜单已经毫无信誉可言了。我不打算读剩下的了。不过我确实很好奇，瑞安·霍华德，他上榜了吗？第一名。好吧，谢天谢地，实至名归，好吧。我不知道。
Those are the people who come to mind. Todd Packer. Oh my gosh, of course, yes. Todd Packer. Yes, yes, yes. Okay. Jan, Jan makes the list. What's so horrible about Jan?
这些人都是我脑海中浮现的。托德·帕克。哦天哪，当然了，是的。托德·帕克。是的，是的，是的。好吧。简，简上榜了。简有什么好糟糕的？
Well, she made Michael sleep on a bench at the foot of the bed. Well, she made him get a vasectomy multiple times or something. All right, I'm sorry. Fine, fine. I'll give it. Gabe.
嗯，她让迈克尔睡在床尾的长凳上。嗯，她好几次逼他去做输精管切除手术什么的。好吧，对不起。好吧，好吧。我让步。盖布。
Gabe? He really cringes people out. They are cringe creeped out by him. Is cringed out a phrase? Probably not. But remember he did film Stanley secretly for his movie and then Oscar's grandmother. Remember he's creepy. All right, that's creepy, that's creepy.
盖布？他真的让人觉得毛骨悚然、尴尬癌都要犯了。大家都被他恶心到了。“Cringed out”算是个短语吗？大概不算。但你记得他曾秘密拍摄斯坦利来制作他的电影，还有奥斯卡的祖母。记住，他很诡异。好吧，那确实很诡异，很诡异。
And then number five, Dwight. Dwight? Yeah, I mean, people think he's a menace. He throws snowballs at you until you're freaked out. He killed Angela's cat. He's always doing these safety drills that put people in harm's way. He did cut off the face of that CPR dummy.
然后是第五名，德怀特。德怀特？是的，我的意思是，人们觉得他是个祸害。他朝你扔雪球，直到把你吓坏。他杀死了安吉拉的猫。他总是进行那些让人们置身于危险之中的安全演习。他还切下了那个心肺复苏模拟人的脸。
That's pretty creepy. Yeah, and that was the beginning of the end for that one Reddit user. Yes, exactly. Oh my goodness. Well, all right, interesting theories. There you go. Do we want to do a poll?
那确实挺诡异的。是的，那对那个Reddit网友来说就是噩梦的开始。是的，完全是。哦天哪。好吧，好吧，有趣的理论。就是这样。我们要不要发起一个投票？
Do you think Dunder Mifflin is the HE double hockey sticks place? We'll find out what you think. But thank you everyone for writing in all your letters, all your theories, your questions, your comments. We just love you guys. We love hearing from you. Lady, should we end with a key anecdote? Oh yes, let's see. All right, here's a key anecdote from 2016. Keanu said, quote, people can't be excellent to you unless you're
你们觉得邓德米夫林真的是那个H-E双冰球棍的地方吗？我们会看看大家的想法。但非常感谢大家写信来分享你们所有的来信、理论、问题和评论。我们太爱你们了。我们喜欢听到你们的声音。女士们，我们要以基努的名言来结束吗？哦，是的，让我们听听。好吧，这是2016年的一条基努语录。基努说：“除非你对自己好，否则别人无法对你好。”
being excellent to yourself. Oh, Keanu. Oh, Keanu. When you're right, you're right, Keanu. It's true. It's true. You cannot accept love into you if you are not already loving yourself.
哦，基努。哦，基努。基努，你说的太对了。确实如此。确实如此。如果你自己都不爱自己，你就无法接受别人的爱。
I mean, it's true. Yeah, I think that's the perfect Keanu Dote to end this episode on. I mean it's true. Yeah I think that's the perfect key anecdote to end this episode on. I agree. Everyone thank you so much and we'll see you next week. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
我的意思是，真的如此。是的，我觉得这是为本集画上句号的完美基努语录。我的意思是真的如此。是的，我觉得这是为本集画上句号的完美基努语录。我同意。各位，非常感谢大家，我们下周见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。“办公室女士”是Audyssey出品的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。
And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科。Audyssey的执行制作人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉雅·里斯-丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴西尔混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。